caneloverse plant oh my god i sent out a
video
this is one of the this is so cool so uh
canelo alvarez uh the best boxer
right now that is not named jake paul
uh
the best boxer ever lived the best boxer
on the planet canela alvarez uh i
believe that he has won
titles
uh 147 pounds 154 pounds 160 pounds 168
pounds and 175 pounds i believe good
punch people in the head he's [ __ ]
incredible yeah
and he's going up against an undefeated
fighter named caleb plant i believe
uh caleb is his first name but plant
what no
that's how mark's ass looks
mark you you got you got not even close
i got him
so they're going and they're having
their face off right the fight's not
until november yep or october then
november 6th oh it's november yeah and
then so the fight uh
is happening for the super middleweight
uh championship that is 168 pounds or
maybe he hasn't won 175 but 168 he's one
so they're having this face off they're
jawing at each other canelo pushes
caleb plant caleb plant comes back
and tries to slap canelo i just want you
guys to watch this video
and i want you to pay attention to
canelo's right hand
right before he swings back at caleb
plant just watch his right hand
keep watch his right hand
watch his right hand
did you see what he did he threw
something out he he's holding his
glasses
in his right hand right and when caleb
plant throws a slap at him
he dodges the slap
go
at the same time throws away his [ __ ]
glasses and then catch his plant with a
left uppercut and then right hand over
the top
oh that's fire huh that full speed it is
unbelievable watch this watch us he
comes back watch us
boom boom boom
oh that's now al before you uh you're
covering uh
mark no i i'm not
barely but let's just get that screen
down so
um
the refl okay so a couple things happen
one right here caleb plan is doing the
right thing to like really hype this
fight and i've never seen canelo have
this type of animosity so i'm actually
interested i'm gonna buy the fight they
did one thing i'm gonna buy the fight
caleb plant got cut under his eye didn't
look like that bigger cut but it's gonna
stop him from doing certain training
like he won't be able to spar right
because you want to make sure that thing
heals up and it could open up very
easily in the fight so kind of stupid
thing but this will definitely add i
mean like hundreds of thousands of
pay-per-view buys for this fight what
they did was unbelievable should happen
in every [ __ ] fight what i'm
interested in is
caleb plant just found out how [ __ ]
fast canelo is
if you notice something really specific
about this
canelo pulls back to avoid the slap
but doesn't leave punching range yeah
yeah yeah
so
he pulls back he's in church shoes
like there's no way i could even throw a
punch in those shoes i'm slipping
sliding all over the place moves back
watch
plants his foot steps back in
uppercut left hand boom open hand open
hand yeah and he's so [ __ ] smart to
throw it yeah he throws it open and hits
him with his uh
and then goes over the top but the
brilliant both were both over and think
about how brilliant that is in the
moment one you don't break your fingers
or knuckles yeah two you don't do too
much damage to him where it's gonna push
back the fight that you've already been
training for yeah yeah
it's not worth the risk
right
i mean
to have that wherewithal like this is
the type of reflexes that you've been
having to do this since you were
uh six years old yeah there's uh there's
a documentary you guys can watch it if
you want or not i'm not too sold on it
right now but it's called schumacher and
it's about michael schumacher on uh the
f1 champion seven time f1 world champion
arguably the greatest uh f1 driver ever
like some people say air tencent was but
doesn't [ __ ] matter but
it's a really interesting story about
this guy schumacher schumacher was
driving these go-karts which is usually
how people get started driving since he
was a kid because his dad owned a
karting a place right in germany and
they would work on the carts and try the
carts and they were basically getting
scrap material to put these things
together he always had the worst tires
the worst things and he said he loved
beating the competition with worse [ __ ]
because it means he had to out drive him
and this is what happened is he learned
how to have such a connection with a car
right from a super young age
that he was able to excel in his own
ability right he had less so he had to
do more he had to get so he could
achieve more
this right here what you're watching
those type of
knee jerk really reflexes like
unbelievable timing like
he doesn't know he's gonna swing on him
he doesn't know if he's gonna push him
when you're in a fight you know that
you're gonna get hit with one or two
hands
this he doesn't know he's actually
welcoming into punching range he's also
thinking there's no way this guy's gonna
punch me because he's not gonna risk the
biggest payday he's ever had in his life
yeah and then in a split second
to pull back
slap slap counter so well yeah
chance that that was staged i'm saying
that there has to be followed me right
now
i know some people are saying this some
people are saying this that it's
potentially staged if it is absolutely
brilliant i'm glad that it staged this
stage
it staged the push was so hard and the
fact that both men
struck with open hands like he did a
one-two open hand yeah who does a
one-two open it wrestling
yeah wrestling which is nice
no no they do the stop
i think what this is this is this is
just me i thought about it potentially
being staged um
i don't think it is because i think
these guys know what's on the line
and
i think there's animosity but at the
same time there's millions of dollars at
stake
and it is not worth
millions of dollars to keep your hands
close when you're gonna be able to punch
the [ __ ] out of that person in a second
i think caleb was just trying to land a
clean slap on canelo like because he
he's slapping he gets his fingers touch
him and i think if he lands a clean slap
he's like oh that's gonna make waves
everybody's gonna talk about this and i
think
he had no clue that canelo was gonna
come back because he cut him
so it's like
he tried to slap him and i think what he
basically learned in this fight is
i'm not as quick as this [ __ ] do
you think you can actually learn
something from this like yeah he learns
he's [ __ ]
he really thinks a 100 he learned i
think he learned i'm gonna have to bully
this guy i'm gonna have to lean on him
there's no way i'm gonna be able to out
point him because if we're just going
punt for punch he's gonna be able to
slip my [ __ ] and counter and there's
nothing i can do so in a way is this a
benefit for him that he's like got this
little trial under his belt he's like oh
he's got hands i gotta box him in he
must know this already but i think it
hurts him because his confidence
okay it helps him in that his confidence
has dipped now but now he can find a
different way to beat him yeah because
he could go into camp going well i'll
just you know punch with him and i'll
try to counter him and now he's like no
i'm gonna have to find a different way
to hurt him yeah because i'm not gonna
be able to just exchange so it probably
helps him at the end of the day it
probably helps him most because now he
can have a strategy that is different
than what he thought he might be able to
do because remember every fight that
he's gone into before this he's won he's
never experienced somebody who could
beat him
and i don't think he's ever even had an
exchange like that in the ring where
he's like oh [ __ ]
i just tried to slap someone
when they were standing right in front
of me and he got two slaps on me in a
second he's not even standing there with
his hands up yeah his hands are at his
hips yeah imagine in the ring knees bent
boxing shoes hands up
you don't have a chance kiddo yeah so
yes confidence is going to dip but maybe
builds that confidence back up in camp
by doing a different type of technique
what i'm saying if the if the guaranteed
outcome was that he was going to lose
and just get absolutely pieced up at
least now he has some preparation and
then when it happens in the ring he's
not surprised yeah he's like okay i
expected this i remember getting slapped
two months ago yep 100
so i'm almost like
i mean if you're gonna get a trial this
is the best time to do it kind of good
yeah yeah i think i think it stays
because don't they have usually this
some law or rule like oh if you put your
hands on this person it's like a crime
or some [ __ ] like that like boxers their
actual hands their hands are like
something like that yeah but i think
that like must have had to be agreed on
yeah but i think that's one of those
things where it's like um
that you have to charge that person with
the assault
and he's not going to press charges
because he wants to fight the guy and
the other guy's not going to press
charges against himself or you know what
i mean
but uh i also think that you can say
like
he can say i was pushed i was worried
for my safety yeah you know
did we do we could were we able to hear
what was said to make legendaries some
mom [ __ ]
but i think it could be lost in
translation he's like listen here
[ __ ] and then
he just hears mother and [ __ ]
so he's like are you saying that my
mother was a [ __ ]
you know like and then just push yeah
because they were drawn a little bit but
how much more exciting is boxing when
you know they don't like each other yeah
[ __ ] all this respect [ __ ]
i respect the craft
yeah that's great you want to do a craft
then do a [ __ ] craft yeah you know
what i mean i want [ __ ] angry
at each other yeah going in there
reckless wanting to take you down
like that is the stakes are so much
higher there's so much more to lose
you get knocked out by the person who
slapped you yeah she is now some people
are saying that it's like the showtime
[ __ ] up like i think dana white said
that i saw it on twitter that he was
saying to like the showtime should have
done something she should have had
security they should have had someone
between them like whenever dana does
wins he's always standing right between
them yeah like if some [ __ ] happens he
can at least step in the middle dana
knows he ain't security
if jon jones wants to fight dc
there is nothing dana can do and dana
knows that right now dana might be able
to hold back like the 145 pound guys
right but if the 200 plus but just him
putting himself in there like these guys
respect him they don't want to oh that's
true
the one that's swinging
yeah
he's [ __ ] brave for that [ __ ] i'm not
standing in between francis and kanu
and stipe
if they're actually angry at each other
i want help put one of them takate girls
in there
i need separation give me a buffer yeah
i'm not doing that on my own but i think
dana's doing what he's supposed to do
which is [ __ ] on any other promotion
that's interesting yeah like that this
is this is a branding game here baby
yeah like the brand is ufc and if you're
not ufc your [ __ ] sucks yeah simple as
that so say why this is bad say why
they're [ __ ] up also who's promoting
uh jake paul's fights
i don't know
that's right
talk about fighting conor mcgregor with
the greatest first pitch in history
this is
i haven't seen it yet i didn't realize
it was oh watch it was like that
i'm shocked he's standing after what he
went through
[Laughter]
that [ __ ]
i mean come on
which first off if you're gonna throw a
first pitch practice practice right like
i think about this whole time if i ever
get to throw a first pitch i'm go i'm in
the gym for weeks like i'm working on it
i'm [ __ ] you're just batting practice
just like getting that hockey they think
oh it's just throwing so i'm throwing
that [ __ ] as hard as possible and i'm
taking the risk it's either gonna be way
off or it's gonna be a strike going like
75 yeah and they're gonna be like yo he
came right here you don't realize how
far that [ __ ] is you get to the top of
like an mlb mound you're like oh [ __ ]
this is some distance here no if you've
never thrown a baseball you gotta
practice before you do it he's not even
from america like he's never even played
baseball with his buddies like
i would never in a million years be like
oh yeah i could throw a cricket i could
throw i could throw a cricket ball
whatever that [ __ ] is no way
yeah i don't know what the ball is
called i guess it's assuming it's called
the cricket i would never throw a
cricket full speed and be like yeah i
could throw this quick it didn't hit the
wickets the quickest yeah
hit the wickets with the cricket i'm not
i don't know
is the [ __ ] word nerd struggling dude
no i mixed wicked with cricket which if
you knew anything about cricket you know
it's called a quickit how many points is
a wicket
six you [ __ ] [ __ ] well it depends
if you hit both then it's more than six
no it's not yeah it is it's always six
always even if you have both yes and
what if you don't hit it
six as well and what if you knock it
down on accident with your butt six
and what if the game's cancelled
six
rain delays six seven six seven that's
why these games go forever
nobody wins i'm just getting points
people die
is that true yeah